happy birthday happy birthday to you one  out of every five kids in America lives  in poverty it's 20 percent fourteen  point eight million kids  if one sprinkle represents a hundred  kids we'd still need way more sprinkles  some children living in poverty don't  have access to running water or medical  care they may not have school supplies  or heat in the winter if they even have  a home  so where do most of these children live  keep going more MORE  not done yet almost there okay now  you're finished children live in poverty  almost everywhere in America when it  comes to developed countries the u.s. is  in the top third struggling with child  poverty  so what can you do to help every Red  Nose makes a difference  [Music]